you guys if you're looking to start a
podcast and you have any av needs i
would reach out to claudia because she
is an expert on the situation thank you
so much for saying that i really
appreciate it because yesterday was the
hardest day of my life but guitar center
was a gorgeous experience guitar center
was like a brief reprieve it's just so
funny in the chaos of our day if you are
thinking i need to go to an electronic
store everyone's like i need to go to
best buy and i'm here to tell you you
don't need to go to best buy like i'm
becoming an anti-best buy activist
because it's not the best buy it should
be called worst buy like they have
nothing and it's just the worst store
and i totally forgot like people think
guitar center like just sends sells
guitars no they are literally the most
friendly
well stocked well air conditioned store
on the planet it was such a pleasant
experience there was a pianist who was
just practicing on the keyboard adding
such an amazing soundtrack to our day no
it was literally like the opera like it
was a gorgeous gorgeous show it was
really gorgeous